[Music]
[Applause]
Jamal Crawford's got his headphones on
listen to the music Boz Scaggs not a bad
uh vibe there what do you think
I love it uh that song it's amazing when
you listen to music like that I wonder
if he knew that we'd still be planted 20
30 years later you know what I mean so I
I think it was it's great what kind of
music would you listen to before a game
you know what I used to do Dan I would
listen to the same music I listened to
in high school so it could be Mariah
Carey it could be uh Jay-Z it could be
Tupac it could be anything I listen to
at that moment because I want to be as
free as I was on the court in high
school in the NBA so I try to put myself
in that mindset would you meet Mariah
Carey
I actually did meet Mariah Carey in New
York when I was there uh she came to a
game I believe in my first year there
and met her and I was like wow like I
used to play you when I was in high
school so it was pretty cool for sure
but when's the last time you remember or
first time you remember like looking at
somebody in the stands and going damn
that's such and such
oh the first time uh I would say it's
probably a Q-tip when I was with Chicago
the Bulls and and he told the story I
was out of game and he was shocked I was
having a pretty good game and I'm taking
the ball out of bounds right in front of
him I was like oh yeah I love tripod
question by the way continue the man I
threw the ball and he started cracking
up laughing he's like how did you even
know I was right there I'm like I'm
always pretty in tune with who was there
that's good stuff all right the official
uh introduction Jamal Crawford former
Sixth Man of the Year NBA TV one of our
favorites here give me the expectation
level you would have as a teammate of
Victor one by Yama in San Antonio
well it depends if I'm a veteran
teammate or from a younger team you're a
veteran
I'm a veteran I would say you know what
we've seen a lot of guys come in the
league uh obviously not quite with the
same amount of height but I will look at
the good that he does obviously he he's
a unicorn Dan have you seen anything
like him no I I Ralph Sampson comes to
mind yes that's a good call yeah so
Ralph was similar but he didn't have the
handle or the range but he he was a
different seven four than we'd ever seen
before in the league
yeah he's like a combination of guys and
what I love is is when you talk to him
or you listen to him his focus is there
and I'm not sure he could have went to a
better place in San Antonio obviously
pop is the man and and having Duncan and
Manu and Tony and David Robinson all
these great guys over the years I'm sure
have a great system in place uh to
develop if I'm a veteran guy I'm gonna
say Young fella we're going to put our
head down we're going to work don't let
your highs get you higher your Low's too
low this is we're just going to continue
to work and continue to work and keep
doing that she'll be special but how do
I use him on the court on the offensive
end
I think he kind of determines that
what's he ready for is he ready to go on
the perimeter is he ready to play out
the mid post
is he ready to held the ball and pick
and roll I think that's how I'm looking
at him because he's so unique with such
a skill set it's about which one's ahead
of which first in the pros because it's
going to be a little bit different for
sure but also trying to figure this out
that when I was growing up if you were
tall don't even think about coming out
to the perimeter now these guys all want
to come out to the perimeter but that
leaves the lane I mean inside is open
here that these guys it feels like those
are easy twos you could have but I don't
know if anybody wants easy twos anymore
now they want the easier three right
it's funny in my Pro-Am I was sitting up
watching them talk and I was looking
down and not one guy in the warm-ups not
even the big guys went there for a laugh
they're all shooting jumpers then I'm
like look look where the game is going
now right like everybody wants to shoot
the three ball and everybody can work on
that so I think it's appealing to to the
world it's universally appealed but I
wonder about this though Jamal our
three-point shooter is going to be like
running backs in the NFL that you can
find them because everybody's going to
be able to shoot that and then you can
find running backs I mean the Kansas
City Chiefs had a seventh round draft
pick uh on their Super Bowl winning team
it I just feel like the guy who can
shoot the three that's going to be
commonplace and you'll be able to you
know guy gets too much money or gonna
want too much money move on we'll find
another three and D guy
right right that's a good question but I
really am interested to see if the big
man right will come back or the going
inside or just not shooting threes will
come back after Denver's won it the way
Joe kernels guys did it so it'll be
interesting obviously there's no Jokers
out there but I'm just interested to see
if the game will kind of revert back
because you know it's a copycat League
okay but what would Shaq be doing now if
he was coming out of college
oh my goodness Dan who's Garden first
off you're probably putting like a power
four on them because there's no more
true center it's very few right so yeah
Shaq would do whatever he wanted to do I
mean kavan Looney is not going to shut
down Shaq
no no disrespect to come on but I'm not
like he was already the most dominant in
that physical error like in this era he
would Shack me even try to dust off some
of his point guard skills from high
school and bring it up drop it off and
build a little bit of everything right
because this is it's that it's that
League now yeah but I mean the league is
built upon these big men is Kareem going
to be a three-point shooter uh Hakeem or
David Robinson or I mean run down the
list of all these great big men who who
made their Hall of Fame names by playing
inside
yes and I would hope these GMS are smart
enough to allow their guys to to play to
their strengths right like everybody
should not be a three-point shooter it's
not for everybody we can't just say okay
uh you know Dwight Howard late in his
career like you're gonna start shooting
threes like no you go dominate inside
right and then we'll work out from there
but then you have Brook Lopez who didn't
take threes who extended his career by
being able to make threes
yeah he's I want to say he's an anomaly
I wouldn't want Shaq doing that I
definitely would not want yeah right I
wouldn't want uh oh my goodness so many
dominant guys in there like that can Dom
Tim Duncan I wouldn't want him just
stepping out shooting threes all the
time yeah because he'd try to bank him
we're talking to Jamal Crawford NBA TV
give me tell me how it works with Chris
Paul and Golden State
that's a great question
um I think if they start him I think
he's he comes out early kind of like you
did in Houston uh you know probably
comes out the five minute Mark comes
back in the second quarter and runs the
second quarter unit as well so he has a
lot of second unit guys around him with
a ball is still in his hands but now if
you're stuck you have two point guards
and and for Golden State you have
another thinker you always want as many
high IQ thinking guys as possible
especially when you're a championship
team like they are
yeah I think he's going to come off the
bench I think he would be a great guy to
have coming off the bench to help those
younger players I mean they gotta
eventually kaminga has to show me that
he can take that next step and I I
wonder if Chris Paul
because I gotta limit his minutes too
maybe around 25 minutes a night uh I
don't want him playing 32 minutes I I
gotta limit that and then all of a
sudden he leads the second wave at least
that would be the approach but I'm also
wondering about I I and I was told these
two things golden state was interested
in Chris and Draymond would not come
back to Golden State if Jordan pool was
still there
Jordan Poole gets knocked out and then
gets sent to Washington that seems that
seems mean spirited Jamal
no that that one I didn't see coming I
did not see that trade coming whatsoever
like I thought Jordan Poole was you know
they committed to him he just helped him
win the championship the year before
well who would you keep would you keep
Jordan pool or you would keep Draymond
well it depends on what you need I think
for Golden State Draymond is
kind of more vital to their success just
because he does such he takes such
responsibility being the point forward
right I'm not sure I've ever seen well
I'm sure I have but very few
combinations have I ever seen that kind
of needed each other as much with Steph
and Draymond so if it comes down to it
it has to be the Draymond Stephanie they
have to kind of go together and once he
opted out now it's like okay we
definitely have to resign it we can't
lose him and that's where things start
taking both
if Damian Lillard called you
yes ask for advice
have you talked to Dame Lillard I have
not talked okay if he reached out and
said
we just got another younger guy we keep
getting younger I'm getting older I'm
not going to be playing in big games
what advice would you give him
I would tell him to stay the course I
think
out of all the guys that were in the
draft I believe I truly believe scoop
even though he's young is the most NBA
ready physically uh most ready mentally
I did interview with him and just
hearing his answers and how he looks at
things and how he approaches things and
I asked him I said so you at 17 years
old your parents since you're across
country I said that's the kudos to you
and them that they trust you enough to
go there and that you're ready for that
right but so if I'm Dame I'm saying you
know what I'm gonna give this young kid
a chance
I know he's young but if I go get
another let's say All-Star if he can
bring the same kind of impact in year
one then maybe I can grow from here but
I'm not giving a lot of time I'll
probably give it half a season see how
it works out and then I'm not getting
younger from Dame I'm ready to go win a
championship yeah you know what's weird
what would you tell him Ben what would
you tell I would say what is going to
make you happy
like you've given Portland everything
yes if you leave you come back they're
going to give you a standing ovation you
know it's not like Chris Paul when he
leaves he comes back to New Orleans or
Houston you know Dame is part of
Portland's basketball landscape forever
but I want to know like what what is the
joy that you're going to get now from
playing basketball and where are you
going to get that Joy because he can get
30 a night
but so what
you want I'd rather you got 25 and they
were meaningful games and that America
got remember we fell in love with him
because we got to see him on a big stage
and he hit big shots yes you know I feel
bad it's like Mike Trout playing
baseball he got three playoff games
against Kansas City hadn't played in any
playoff games since then
but Dan is the ultimate win for him to
say you know what I'm Gonna Leave You
when this is all said like a dirt like a
Steph Curry in a league where it's such
change that I'm the one pillar I have an
opportunity to be the best player to
ever play here and I stay here my whole
career yeah but they build around stuff
and they build around Dirk
that's the difference if that's a big
difference that's a big difference and
that that's where you know your head or
your heart which one you're gonna go
with at that point right and that's with
the battle at some point that he's gonna
approach if they don't change things
fast and we don't value loyalty in
sports whether it's a player to a team
or you know an owner or coach to a
player and Dame is giving you loyalty
here and somehow will find fault in that
like kg when he was in Minnesota it's
like dude you know you got to get out
Hey sir left three years before right
that's what we'll be saying at the top
yeah yeah it's a tough one it's a tough
one but also you played for what 16 17
teams
and well nine if you count the one in
the bubble two you got to give me that
one too that bubble game give me a year
in it and then it gave me a year it gave
me yeah
did you keep all your jerseys
no I only have two in my house actually
I have uh my next one and my my clippers
one and both teams traded me loyalty
right go figure you played six minutes I
think for Brooklyn didn't you
if I had five points three assists in
six minutes then and I've played 16
months I said you know what this is
still like it did right when I left 16
months ago absolutely you know if we
prorate that you know you're getting 37
at night I mean you're killing it yes
and I came back against the best team in
the league at that time I said I want to
come back against Orlando I want
Milwaukee jackpot looked at me like I
was crazy you sure you want them I say
yes what's what's the worst the worst
way you found out you got traded
oh
the worst what you know what if you go
back the Knicks actually I was playing
we were in Milwaukee and Mike dantonia
just did a sit-down interview with John
Thompson the late John John Thompson the
rest of Peace on TNT and they were
talking he was like yeah you know it's a
market average you know 25 here 30 here
whatever he can be you know a great
great score I'm in Milwaukee shoot
around I hear a rumor and I'm like well
he just stopped managing 25 or 30
there's no way I'm not planning to walk
you ain't helped me out that night Dan
that was it it took me three days to
recover from that one well no no I think
he was saying you could average 25 a
night just not with just not here yeah
just not here yeah he said it yeah he
said in Golden State you'll get more uh
shots of running up and down so yeah
that's what happened that was shocking
hey great to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us it's uh LeBron
played last year in your summer league
he did is he playing this year
I don't know if he's playing this year
uh but we will have some Superstars
playing this year and hopefully and even
if he doesn't he definitely helped the
momentum with guys coming Superstar
stepping up so we'll see what happens is
that just he shows up and then you go oh
damn LeBron's here
no he actually texted me a little bit
before some people working behind the
scenes absolutely Shantae Murray was
working behind the scenes cups working
behind the scenes so many guys kind of
pushing it forward we had talked about
it and it just didn't add up but the
timing was right he was excited he then
he was so excited he wanted his jersey
delivered uh to the hotel like it was
AAU he really wanted to throw on a great
show so kudos to him for that
uh thank you again Jamal always great to
talk to you thank you that's uh Jamal
Crawford one of her favorites NBA TV